In a world where nobody makes mistakes, there
might never be a need for superheroes.
But in the real world nobody is perfect—including
the men and women who made the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
From The Avengers to X-Men, the folks behind
our favorite superhero movies are just as
human as the rest of us.
Here are a few mistakes you might have needed
super-vision to spot.
Deadpool: Strange selfies
Deadpool's plans don't often go exactly as
he's intended—
"I forgot my ammo bag!"
"Should we turn back?"
"Nope, no time, I got this."
"Nine, ten, eleven, twelve bullets...or bust.
Right here!"
-and apparently, neither do his selfies.
During one of the fleeting happy moments in
the pre-super life of Wade Wilson, he takes
a cuddly photo with his lady.
But when we see the actual Polaroid, both
the poses and the smiles are completely different.
And it’s not the only time Deadpool’s
picture makes a sudden change...
Deadpool: The evolving self-portrait
During Deadpool's elaborate opening sequence,
we see a tattered, burning sketch that shows
our anti-hero using swords to decapitate a
nameless bad guy.
But when Deadpool creates the crayon self-portrait
later, he's using guns and the rest of the
doodle has changed.
Napoleon Dynamite wouldn’t have made that
mistake!
Gosh!
"Freaking idiot!"
Iron Man: Pepper's high-tech headset
Tony Stark may be a billionaire playboy with
next-level technology, but even he doesn't
have invisible Bluetooth headsets.
However, his assistant Pepper apparently does.
After a quick cut away in Iron Man, the wireless
headset she's wearing during a phone call
disappears faster than Terrence Howard disappeared
from the cast of Iron Man 2.
Owww.
"Next time baby"
The Amazing Spider-Man 2: The amazing backpack
Peter Parker obviously has a lot of stuff
to deal with, and can't be expected to know
what's going on with his accessories at all
times.
After just barely making it to Gwen Stacy's
graduation ceremony in The Amazing Spider-Man
2, his backpack repeatedly jumps from one
shoulder to both.
With great power comes… well, lousy continuity.
Ant-Man: Gun fever
One of the many upsides to being Ant-Man is
that you're able to control swarms of ants
with your mind.
That comes in particularly handy when the
villainous Darren Cross holds a gun to the
head of Ant-Man and an army of ants jam the
gun's firing hammer.
However, the type of pistol Cross is holding
throughout the scene doesn't have the external,
revolver-type hammer that's shown in the close-up.
But let’s hear it for those noble ants anyway.
Gambit's receding facial hair
There's no shortage of hairy men in Wolverine's
world, but Gambit takes it to the extreme
in X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
When he encounters Wolverine in a bar, he's
got a scruffy mustache and beard.
But after knocking Wolverine through a wall,
he's suddenly far more clean-shaven, making
it clear the scenes were shot on different
days.
Spider-Man: Don't turn around
Sometimes the science behind Spider-Man's
web-slinging is a little iffy, but it's not
Spidey who breaks the laws of physics here.
During a scene in Spider-Man in which large
chunks of a building are seen about to fall
on a lovely couple, we see the pair as they
run screaming towards the camera.
But just a split-second later when Spider-Man
is about to pull them to safety, they're instantly
facing the other way…and not in much of
a hurry.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier: Uh, where
are we now?
For a movie about top secret military operatives
and ultra-advanced technology, there's a pretty
loose approach to geography in Captain America:
The Winter Soldier.
The filmmakers post the location SHIELD HQ
onscreen.
Although the latitude seems correct, the longitude
is listed as "south" when it should be "west."
Avengers: Age of Ultron: She's a witch!
Although this mistake might seem minor, it's
incredibly jarring to see it play out in real
time.
As the Scarlet Witch talks to Captain America
in a scene from Avengers: Age of Ultron, she's
got her head tilted to the left side of the
screen.
But in the next shot from further back, she's
tilting her head the other way.
Wait, what movie was this again?
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know your
favorite Marvel mistakes...